[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
des mutations alors la première battle
va opposer
allez c'est parti on fait tourner la
roue très bas voilà c'est jean claude
van damme par marc-antoine le bruit pour
goûter offert bazire oui j'ai tourné
avec lui au plus facile facile alors
bonjour à ces vandales du maroc ou si je
veux leur bonheur marc-antoine hockey
bonjour envoie jean claude van damme
on va pouvoir faire des chants bretons
en faisant nolwenn leroy merlin
il faut sauver les dauphins dit non
gratin dauphinois
je l'avais unis en voiture je suis passé
à font marche arrière devant un radar ne
sais quoi j'ai récupéré six points de
perm est directe
bravo jean avec tout un grand schtroumpf
genre eh ben tu as they had effet le bon
jour où les enfants c'est parfois web et
ses pairs fouras qui rend compte le
grand chelem
tu t'es de labatut deuxième bateau la
[Musique]
légitimité
francis une inimitable vas-y un échec
dans un instant je vous le dis on va
regarder des images de nous dans notre
édition d'hier autres a commenté des
images de nous dans notre émission
d'armentières quand on se regarde et il
ya trois jours en train de mater des
images de loudéac
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
manipuler chéri on y va ces partiques
pas et après que j'adore avec vous aussi
really un truc que j'adore c'est que
parfois on émission quand je les
travaille avec vous si on repart été par
que vous avez de vous et de la revente
revenir que je sois pas une fête
et sinon demain mon cher allez on va
continuer la battle d'imitation c'est
parti on y va en premier comme je vais
te battre vas-y repreneur alors c'est
terrible les migrants des migrants
illégaux et quittent leur pays en guerre
ils font 5000 km et il arrive à calais
première réaction c'est de se dire oh
[ __ ] à tous
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est un truc de fou c'est vrai deux
surprises
jean marie tu sais le faire ou pas du
don peuvent pas du tout au plus alors
regarde j'ai entendu des revendications
regarde déjà les jaunes et ce ne sont
pas des carabistouilles
[Rires]
treize maître mot compte triple à scrubs
j'ai dit que je rencontrerai les maires
région par région je les fais d'après lé
maire je rencontrerai les grands mères
ici j'ai un peu d'énergie je passerai
aux arrière grand mère je laisserai la
totalité des maires de
les vols
[Applaudissements]
ah ouais à la la land au laos et la paix
carlos ghosn dans la mer est ce que vous
savez comment on appelle une figure qui
est ainsi si côté si ce côté malien d un
bain un hexagone
voilà huit de côté aucun autre gone 10
de côté des cadets cadettes 1 million de
côté au ski en seconde bienvenue dans la
housse une émission aux produits par de
là où tu écris pas de la hausse est
présentée par elsa dans son nouveau
spectacle attachement cadeau à droite a
fait un énorme carton tournée dans toute
la france avec ton show il édita patins
castaner sarika stahl arms à 10 ans que
hier soir dans le 8e arrondissement je
croise brigitte maillette macron elle se
retourne je lui claque la bise m dit
monsieur je vous connais pas [ __ ]
c'était patrick juvet néant salut tout
le monde
c'est vrai que là je suis pas très relax
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que vous avez une faction que
vous savez faire vous autour de la table
ce que vous avez une imitation
franchement une voix la voix est
toujours la même c'est quoi malbranque
phase i attention et tu sais très bien
faire que françois aussi à la fin toutes
les semaines
j'te dis toute la semaine on la fera t
qui sait faire que c'est le numéro vas-y
ça fera montre enfin cela fait en effet
faire le canard de caliméro tazi
[Rires]